Guys, it's so hot outside.
Does anybody else hot?
I'm so hot.
I need a glass of water or something.
I need something to cool off.
You know what's going to make me cool off?
A new episode of Smartless.
Hey, guys.
伙计们，外面太热了。还有人觉得热吗？我好热。我需要一杯水什么的。我需要点什么来降降温。你知道什么能让我降温吗？新一期的 Smartless。嘿，伙计们。
Hey.
Will's in Italy.
Oh, my gosh, Will, what time is it in Italy?
Nobody knows.
It's time for a camp party.
Cue the music.
It's a problem for tomorrow, no?
So, Will, have you run into our back-of-the-the-the-the-the-the-theter critic?
嘿。威尔在意大利。哦，天哪，威尔，意大利现在几点？没人知道。是时候开露营派对啦。放音乐。那是明天的事，对吧？所以，威尔，你碰到我们的后，后，后，后，后，后，后台影评人了吗？
Oh, every...
about here. What a podcast.
This guy, what a body
on him. Nobody knew.
I see him on the Italian beaches now.
No way. At Fis 56,
I'll eat my hat.
We did have, we did have,
哦，差不多……大概在这。多棒的播客啊。这家伙，这身材真绝了。谁都不知道。我现在在意大利海滩上看到他了。不可能。在 56 岁的时候，要是真的，我把帽子吃下去。我们确实有，我们确实有，
we had, we're up in,
we're on the Italian Riviera right now
and let me tell you something. It's fantastic.
That's a Portofino.
Porto just drove up here today. Just drove
up where was at a wedding in Tuscan
Sure.
But I did have a guy the other day
我们有，我们在，我们现在就在意大利里维埃拉，我跟你说件事。太棒了。那是菲托菲诺。波托今天刚开车到这儿。刚开到……之前在托斯卡纳参加婚礼来着。不过我前几天确实有个家伙
came into the room to look at something
with the AC
and couldn't, with the light,
and couldn't fix it when it go out.
And he said,
that's a problem for tomorrow, no?
With a little smile like that, too?
It's too hot to fix today.
走进房间来看空调有没有问题，结果修不好，灯也是，当它灭了的时候也修不好。然后他说，“那是明天的事，对吧？”还带着那样一丝微笑？今天太热了，修不好。
You know what?
And it was.
It was a problem for tomorrow.
Isn't that so different?
It's so different than us.
I know.
What do you mean you can't fix it here?
Yeah, they take all of August off.
你知道吗？确实如此。那是明天的事。这不是很不一样吗？跟我们太不一样了。我知道。你什么意思，这里修不好？对，他们整个八月都在休假。
Europe does.
It's so good.
It's so, so good.
What about you, J.B., how's the city treating you right now?
The city is all right.
The heat has gone down to 85 and 90% humidity as opposed to 95 and 90% humidity.
Are you shooting outside?
Yeah, yeah, on a farm.
欧洲人就是这样。太棒了。太棒太棒了。那你呢，J.B.，现在城市对你怎么样？城市还行。热度已经降到了 85% 到 90% 的湿度，而不是 95% 到 90% 的湿度。你在室外拍戏吗？对，对，在一个农场里。
Not a lot of shade.
But it's okay.
It's great.
I'm losing water weight, you guys.
You know how I love that.
And Shawnee, how are things for you?
And Sean wants to go and just trying to go from the bedroom to the office
and back up to the bedroom?
没什么阴凉处。不过没关系。挺好的。我在掉水分呢，伙计们。你知道我多喜欢这样。肖妮，你那边情况怎么样？肖恩想去，然后只是试着从卧室走到办公室，再走回卧室？
Try not to sprain your ankle going in and out of the kitchen.
No.
Have you had any more smores dates with yourself?
I had a couple smore of them.
Oh, Sean has been up early.
I was not really.
Anything to update us on in your life, Sean?
Yeah.
尽量别在进出厨房时扭伤脚踝。没。你跟自己有过更多棉花糖约会吗？我有过好几次棉花糖。哦，肖恩起得很早。其实没有。肖恩，你生活中有没有什么最新情况要告诉我们？有。
I did.
Oh, yeah.
I did a, just last night, I did a, with my friend Todd Stashewick, who was an actor.
I went to college with him.
And he hosted a D&D night, a Dungeons and Dragons night.
But I haven't played Dungeons and Dragons in like, since I was like 10 years old.
Since you lost your virginity.
Yeah, because you're 56.
我有。哦，对。就在昨晚，我跟我朋友托德·斯塔什维克一起，他是个演员。我和他一起上的大学。他主持了一个龙与地下城之夜，一个《Dungeons and Dragons》之夜。但我已经好久没玩过龙与地下城了，大概从我 10 岁左右开始。自从你失身以后。对，因为你 56 岁了。
Yeah.
I mean, it adds up.
If you think about it, if you look at it, the math adds up.
Was it kind of him to like throw in the surprise in that sentence?
Like, I haven't played since I was 10.
Can you believe it?
Nor has anyone else.
No, man.
对。我的意思是，这合情合理。如果你想想，如果你仔细看，这数学对得上。他刚才那句话里顺便扔出一个惊喜，是不是挺逗的？就像，我从 10 岁以后就没玩过了。你敢信吗？也没有别人玩过。得了吧，老兄。
No, we really did.
It was so fun.
I mean, it was,
I think Stranger's things
really brought that game back.
So what is it with that?
I never did play it when I was 10.
It's a role-playing thing, right?
不，我们真的玩了。太好玩了。我是说，我觉得《怪奇物语》真的让这个游戏复活了。那这到底是怎么回事？我 10 岁的时候从没玩过。这是个角色扮演游戏，对吧？
Yeah, it's all improvised, yeah.
So, but do you roll dice to find out who can,
who gets the shield, who gets the sword?
Well, and, like, who gets,
and, like, damage and, like, how much damage you did?
Like, did you survive their hit, or did you?
Is that just based on how hard you roll?
Yeah, I know.
对，全都是即兴发挥，对。那么，你是要掷骰子来决定谁能，谁拿到盾牌，谁拿到宝剑吗？还有，比如，谁拿到，还有伤害什么的，比如你造成了多少伤害？比如，你挨了他们一下活下来了没有，还是？这只是完全取决于你掷得有多用劲吗？对，我知道。
Are higher numbers more damage?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
But you know what?
It's like playing a video game, but with your mind.
Oh.
Okay.
数字越大伤害越高吗？对，没错。对，对，就是这样。但你知道吗？这就像是在玩电子游戏，只不过是用你的大脑。哦。哦。好吧。
So you really get carried.
You really just get taken away into a different place.
Wait, I heard this.
I heard this.
You get carried away.
So fun.
Do you want to hear a good joke?
A new pun joke?
所以你真的会沉浸其中。你真的会被带到一个不同的地方。等等，我听过这个。我听过这个。你被深深吸引了。太好玩了。你想听个好笑的笑话吗？一个新的双关笑话？
A dad joke?
Yeah, I've been getting my money's worth out of what did the sushi say to the bumblebee, wasabi.
Everyone's been enjoying that around.
Have they been telling you they enjoyed it when you're the boss?
Well, I see it on their face.
Yeah, sure.
Oh, that's a good one, boss.
Hey, is Jason hit you with that four fucking times too?
一个冷笑话？对，我最近一直在物尽其用——寿司对大黄蜂说了什么？是芥末（wasabi）。大家都在周围玩这个梗。当你是老板的时候，他们有没有对你说他们很喜欢？嗯，我从他们的脸上看出来了。对，当然。哦，这笑话真不错，老板。嘿，杰森是不是也对你说过四次这破笑话了？
Yeah.
He thinks I'm a PA.
I'm a driver.
Over and over again.
You got a freshie for me, Doug?
Yeah.
You guys, oh, God, this is awful.
The new...
对。他以为我是个制片助理。我只是个司机。一遍又一遍。道格，你有什么新鲜货带给我吗？有。伙计们，哦，天哪，这太糟糕了。新……
The guy who invented cough drops died yesterday.
Oh, no.
Yeah, there's not going to be any cough at his funeral.
All right.
I'll take that.
I mean, yeah, they'll love that.
The only...
发明润喉糖的那个人昨天去世了。哦，不。对，他的葬礼上绝对不会有人咳嗽了。好吧。我接受这个。我接受这个。我是说，对，他们会喜欢这个的。唯一的……
Yeah, the only...
And this is not a criticism, Sean.
Come on, that's funny.
You know what is?
It's just that you say,
Coff and cough, you say cough in the setup.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
对，唯一的……这不是批评，肖恩。得了吧，这挺好笑的。你知道有什么问题吗？就是你在铺垫的时候说“咳嗽”（Coff and cough），你把咳嗽读成“coff”。对。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, but the cough.
Oh, right, cough drop.
Well, the guy invented throat lozenges, maybe that's better.
I don't know.
Listen, let's open up a suggestion line for peeps if they want to do, like a punch-up line on SmartLen.
And they can punch up our jokes.
We've got a table together.
Punch-up line, please hold.
对，但是咳嗽。哦，对，润喉糖。好吧，发明咽喉含片的那个人，也许这样更好。我不知道。听着，让我们为听众开通一个建议热线，如果他们想在 SmartLen 上加一句包袱。他们可以帮我们的笑话抖个包袱。我们一起开个桌。抖包袱热线，请保持通话。
Tell you it who doesn't need a punch-up.
Here we go.
This is a segue for segues.
I can tell you, it's a female.
I heard whispering earlier.
She sounds like she's got a pretty whisper voice.
抖包袱热线，请保持通话。我跟你说，谁才不需要抖包袱呢。我们来啦。我们来啦。这是一个转折中的转折。我看得出来，这是个女的。我刚才听到有人在窃窃私语。听起来她有一副很好听的耳语嗓音。
Okay.
Well, aren't you going to be surprised?
No.
He's going to get a great chuckle out of this.
Because he's an Academy Award-winning actor.
Academy nominated director, J.B.
He's made some great films, and I don't use that term lately.
He is...
好吧。哼，你难道不觉得意外吗？不。他会为这个笑话开怀大笑的。因为他是一位奥斯卡奖得主。奥斯卡提名的导演，J.B.。他拍过一些很棒的电影，而且我可不是随便用这个词的。他是……
David Lean.
He's done iconic roles.
And I'm going to go backwards on the...
Kenneth Brana.
As an actor?
I'm going to go back.
I'm not going to lead with some of his most famous rules
because you're just going to know immediately
大卫·里恩。他演过标志性的角色。我要倒着说……肯尼思·布拉纳。作为演员？我要倒回去。我不会先列举他最著名的角色，因为你们马上就会猜到，
because he's just done some of the most iconic films of all the time.
But I'm going to say things like Jacob's Ladder,
the Incredible Bull Durham.
I'm going to say the player, Mr. Grimmard's.
You guys, it's Tim Robbins.
Tim.
Oh my God, Tim Robbins.
Welcome, Tim Robbins.
因为他拍过影史上一些最具标志性的电影。但我要说的是像《异世浮生》、《惊爆点》（Bull Durham）。我要说《大玩家》、《格林先生的……》。伙计们，是蒂姆·罗宾斯。蒂姆。哦，天哪，蒂姆·罗宾斯。欢迎，蒂姆·罗宾斯。
This is really exciting.
So who was the female whisperer?
Was there any...
She's just off camera.
She's just on camera.
No, it's basically someone, because I'm an idiot with technology,
someone that they sent from Apple to help me set up the microphone.
Us granddad's have trouble with it.
这太让人激动了。所以刚才那个窃窃私语的女的是谁？有什么……她就在镜头外。她就在镜头里。不，基本上是有人，因为我对科技是个白痴，苹果公司派来帮我设置麦克风的人。我们这些老头子对这个觉得很头疼。
You have a smartphone, don't you?
You're not still using like a flip phone, are you?
No, rotary.
Oh, no.
Portable rotary.
Oh, God, you carry that with you everywhere you go.
Yeah, I know.
And you have to find, there's fewer and fewer points.
你不是有智能手机吗？你不会还在用那种翻盖手机吧？没有，转盘式的。哦，不。便携式转盘电话。哦，天哪，你无论去哪都随身带着那个。对，我知道。而且你得找，可以插电的地方越来越少了。
places to plug in.
Yeah.
Tim,
it's so overdue
having you here,
first of all,
let me just say that.
Thank you.
插电的地方。对。蒂姆，首先，你能来这里真的是迟来的惊喜，我必须这么说。谢谢你。
It is so overdue.
It's great to have you, man.
It's great to see you.
Such a big fan of yours.
Yeah.
Where, J.B. says,
where are you?
What part of the world are you in?
真的是太久没见了。你能来真是太棒了，老兄。很高兴见到你。我是你的超级粉丝。对。J.B. 说，你在哪儿？你在世界的哪个地方？
East, West Coast.
West Coast.
West Coast, right now.
Oh,
in Los Angeles?
Yes.
Don't give them an address.
东海岸，西海岸。西海岸。现在在西海岸。西海岸。哦，在洛杉矶？对。别给他们地址。
Tim, don't.
Okay.
I'm careful, Tim, don't tell them where.
I can't give you my quadrant.
No.
Dungeons and Dragons set up.
He's going to show up with his golden dye.
He's going to ask you to roll.
蒂姆，别给。好吧。我小心着呢，蒂姆，别告诉他们你在哪。我不能把我的坐标泄露出去。不。龙与地下城布置好了。他要带着他的金色骰子出现了。他会让你掷骰子的。
Roll for damage.
Knock on the darn.
Are we doing a barbecue?
Have you ever played Dungeons and Dragons, Tim?
You know, that's what I missed.
I was more, you know, that kind of long-form, nerdy kind of game.
Mine was stratomatic baseball.
Oh, tell me about that.
掷骰子算伤害。敲门。我们在搞烧烤吗？蒂姆，你玩过《龙与地下城》吗？你知道的，那才是我错过的。我更喜欢那种，你知道的，那种长篇幅的书呆子游戏。我玩的是策略棒球（Strat-O-Matic baseball）。哦，跟我讲讲那个。
You're talking to a baseball cell.
I didn't play, but I'm aware of it.
Tell us a little bit of it.
Really cool.
You know, it's a long, long game, but, you know, you play nine innings and you pick your teams.
And, you know, basically there's a roll of the dice and a multi-sided dice, die that determines whether it's a hit or, you know, a strikeout or grand slas, you know, whatever.
It's very complicated.
Do you pick real players?
你可是在跟一个棒球迷说话。我没玩过，但我知道。给我们讲讲吧。酷得很。你知道，那是个很长很长的游戏，但是，你知道，你要打满九局，你挑选你的球队。然后，你知道，基本上就是掷骰子，一个多面骰子，一个决定是安打，还是，你知道，三振出局或者满垒全垒打，你知道，诸如此类的。这非常复杂。你选的是真实球员吗？
You say you pick your teams.
Yeah, we pick real players.
Yeah.
I haven't played for a while.
Back in the day when Cal Ripkin was on his long streak,
you know, his, I don't think anyone's ever going to break that record of consecutive times played without missing a game.
We kept Cal out of the game.
你说你挑选球队。对，我们挑选真实球员。对。我好久没玩了。在当年小卡尔·里普金连续出场纪录还在的时候，你知道，他的，我觉得没有人能打破那个连续出场且没有缺席一场比赛的纪录了。我们把卡尔排除在比赛之外了。我们把卡尔排除在比赛之外了。
Yeah, we kept them out of the game.
Yeah, just to spite him.
It was Cal won't play.
The Philly was in there.
We ended the streak.
Yeah.
What about fantasy baseball?
我们把卡尔排除在比赛之外了。对，我们把他排除在比赛之外了。是的，纯粹为了跟她作对。卡尔就是不肯上场。费城人在那儿呢。我们终结了纪录。对。那梦幻棒球呢？
Do you play that at all?
I don't.
Cool it, J.B.
Sorry.
Are you a fantasy guy?
Yeah, he's up at 4 a.m.
I'm like the commissioner of my league.
Really?
你玩那个吗？我不玩。冷静点，J.B.。抱歉。你是个狂热玩家吗？对，他凌晨 4 点就起来了。我简直就像是我那个联盟的总裁。真的吗？
It's my Dungeons and Dragons Dork stuff.
Can you be bought?
Sure, everybody's got their price.
Everybody on my team's up for sale.
Except the Dodgers.
Wait, so Tim, were you,
I'm gathering by the fact that you played that,
that you were a lifelong baseball fan,
这就是我的龙与地下城书呆子玩意儿。你能被买通吗？当然，每个人都有自己的价码。我队里的每个人都可以出售。除了道奇队。等等，所以蒂姆，我从你玩过那个游戏推断，你是个终身棒球迷，
and I mentioned Bull Durham,
which I saw in the theater twice.
I loved that movie.
I know it was a million years ago.
It's an iconic movie.
It's one of the great sports movies.
It's not just about sports.
It's about so much more and about...
我提到了《惊爆点》，我在电影院看了两遍。我太喜欢那部电影了。我知道那是好几百万年前的事了。这是一部标志性的电影。它是最伟大的体育电影之一。它不仅仅关乎体育。它关乎更多的事情，关于……
So when you...
I guess you were a big baseball fan,
so when you got the chance to play...
And that character you played...
What was his name?
Nukke.
Was that his name...
Yeah.
所以当你在……我想你是个超级棒球迷，所以当你获得出演机会时……你演的那个角色……他叫什么名字？Nuke。他叫那个名字吗……对。
Eby Calvin, New Clouche.
Yeah.
I mean, were you...
Was that a role when that came your way?
Do you remember the process of getting that?
Were you stoked to get that to play that point?
Oh, are you kidding me?
You know, what the weird thing was that I got cast in another baseball movie the same time,
Ebby Calvin LaLooche。对。我是说，你……当这个角色找上你时，是一次这样的经历吗？你还记得获得这个角色的过程吗？得到这个扮演机会时你是不是很兴奋？哦，你在开玩笑吗？你知道，奇怪的是，我当时还去另一部棒球电影试镜了，
Eight Men Out, that John Sales was directing.
Yeah.
And I loved John Sales.
It was, you know, I had to make a decision, and I'm glad I made the one I did because it kind of shifted everything for me in life.
I was so psyched.
I mean, I did the audition section, and then I got the callback was basically,
you've got to come play some base,
but throw the ball with Kevin Costner, right?
约翰·塞尔斯导演的《八人出局》。对。而且我很喜欢约翰·塞尔斯。当时，你知道的，我必须做出决定，我很高兴我做了现在的选择，因为它在某种程度上彻底改变了我的人生。我当时兴奋极了。我是说，我进行了试镜，然后我接到了回调通知，基本上就是，你得来打打棒球，但是要和凯文·科斯特纳一起传球，对吧？
And so they wanted to see if I could throw.
He didn't want to have to fake any of that stuff.
And could you?
So I had played all my life,
and mostly third base,
and so I had a pretty good arm,
but I didn't know the mechanics of the pitching,
so I had to go, you know, earlier
所以他们想看看我能不能投球。他可不想伪造任何这方面的镜头。你行吗？我从小到大一直在玩，大部分时间打三垒，所以我的手臂力量挺不错的，但我不知道投球的技巧，所以我不得不提前去，你知道，
and try to, you know, put that together.
Did you end up becoming a fairly decent pitcher?
Like, did you learn a couple of pitches?
I did. I got it up to, I got it up to 85.
Wow.
No control at all. No control at all.
I threw it into the stands.
然后试着，你知道，把那些动作组合起来。你最后成了一个相当不错的投手吗？比如，你学会了几种球路吗？是的。我把它练到，我把它练到 85 英里。哇。哇。完全没有控球力。完全没有控球力。我把它直接扔到观众席里去了。
When he hits the bowl, you know, that was basically me.
But I could, I could throw it pretty fast.
And how were you as a hitter?
Pretty good.
Could you get a round on an 85 mile an hour pitch?
No way. No, no.
Oh, no, no. I didn't play.
I grew up in Manhattan.
当他击中那个球时，你知道，那基本上就是我。但我能，我能投得挺快的。你作为击球手怎么样？相当不错。你能应付 85 英里每小时的投球吗？不可能。不，不。哦，不，不。我没玩过。我在曼哈顿长大的。
So we didn't have a lot of, we didn't have a lot of, we didn't have a lot of,
a lot of baseball fields.
Right. Right. You had show leagues.
Yeah. We had concrete playgrounds.
So we played softball.
Gotcha.
And so, mostly softball.
And so I could hit a softball. I could hit very well.
所以我们没有太多，我们没有太多，我们没有太多，很多棒球场。对。对。你们有校际联赛。对。我们有混凝土操场。所以我们玩的是垒球。明白了。所以，大部分是垒球。所以我会打垒球。我打得非常好。
And I still, you know, I still play a little bit.
Do you really?
Yeah. I play first base now, you know.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, yeah.
It's easier.
Tell us about that. Is that just your buddies?
Is that like, is it a show league?
而且我到现在，你知道，我偶尔还会打一打。真的吗？对。我现在打一垒，你知道。嗯哼。对，对。那样比较轻松。给我们讲讲那个。那是你的一帮哥们儿吗？那是个校际联赛吗？
is it, how are you doing that?
Usually just friends, you know, get together.
There's some regular leagues.
When I'm on the East Coast, there's a game I get involved in.
I play hockey that way, too.
Still?
Oh, my God.
We can get so hurt.
还是，你是怎么玩的？通常只是一起聚聚的朋友，你知道的。也有一些常规的联赛。当我在东海岸时，我会参加一个比赛。我也会那样打冰球。现在还打？哦，天哪。我们很容易受伤的。
I have a game every Sunday out here that I'm missing for the show.
You're playing roller hockey, Tim?
Roller. I used to play ice.
I haven't played ice for a while, but I play roller hockey every Sunday.
Tim, I used to play on the Upper West Side.
for you, and I played ice hog, and then when I moved to New York, I used to play up on 84th Street,
and there's a school between Amsterdam and Columbus, and they paved it. And then for some reason,
it wasn't open for like six months. And all these Canadian guys that I knew, and a bunch of American guys,
我在这里每周日都有一场比赛，为了这个节目我都错过了。你在打轮滑冰球吗，蒂姆？轮滑。我以前打过冰球。我好久没打过冰球了，但我每周日都打轮滑冰球。蒂姆，我以前在上西区打过。为你，我打过冰球，然后当我搬到纽约时，我经常在 84 街附近打，阿姆斯特丹大道和哥伦布大道之间有一所学校，他们把那儿铺平了。然后出于某种原因，有大约六个月时间没开放。我认识的所有那些加拿大家伙，还有一帮美国家伙，
we played every, we played all day, Saturday and Sunday, like right when Roller Blades came out,
like 91, 92. So nice. And we, and I lived, I lived by the Holland Tunnel, and I would skate uptown with my stick all the way up to the Upper West Side.
the best through cars and shit.
You know, Tim, Scotty, my husband was a goalie
in an adult ice hockey league in New York
at a place called Skyrink, and he played you guys.
Sure.
No way.
我们每天都在打，周六周日整天都在打，就像旱冰鞋刚出来的时候，大概 91、92 年。太棒了。而且我们，我住在，我住在荷兰隧道旁边，我以前会拿着球棍一路滑旱冰到上西区。穿过车流什么的。你知道，蒂姆，我丈夫斯科蒂以前是纽约一个成人冰球联赛的守门员，在一个叫 Skyrink 的地方，他和你们交过手。真的假的？
Yeah, in the 90s.
Scotty's team played your team,
and he said he took a beast of a shot.
You took a shot on him, it was great,
but he blocked it.
Isn't that wild?
What a small world.
Do you remember Scotty the sieve?
对，在 90 年代。斯科蒂的球队和你们的球队打过，他说他接到了一个非常凶猛的射门。你朝他射门了，那球太棒了，但他挡出去了。这不是很疯狂吗？世界真小。你还记得漏勺斯科蒂吗？
Scotty the sieve.
Isn't that wild?
What a small world.
Wow.
That's crazy.
I remember Sky.
Goldies are a special breed, by the way.
你还记得漏勺斯科蒂吗？漏勺斯科蒂。这不是很疯狂吗？世界真小。哇。太疯狂了。我记得 Sky。顺便说一句，守门员是一个特殊的群体。
They sure are.
There's well.
I used to be a goalie.
I was a goalie growing up.
Really?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Wouldn't you agree there's something different about them?
确实是。当然。我以前是个守门员。我从小就是个守门员。真的吗？哦，对。对，对。你不同意他们身上有点与众不同吗？
The kind of weird...
It's like the catcher in baseball.
It's usually the brains of the bunch.
Well, there's always that thing.
They always say that goalies are the best skaters on the team
because they have to be really nimble.
I don't know if that's necessarily true.
But I think that goalies, you know,
那种奇特的感觉……就像棒球里的捕手。通常是一群人里头脑最好的人。嗯，总有那种说法。人们总说守门员是队里滑冰最好的，因为他们必须非常敏捷。我不知道这是否一定正确。但我认为守门员，你知道，
They're spending a lot of time.
Think about it.
Even in soccer, too, they spend a lot of time on their own,
and then all of a sudden they've got to kind of perform.
I know.
They're the king of their own little domain, you know what I mean?
So they have to have a certain temperament.
I don't know.
他们花了很多时间。想想看，即使在足球里也是如此，他们有很长的时间都是孤身一人，然后突然之间他们就得表现自己。我知道。他们是自己小世界里的国王，你知道我的意思吗？所以他们必须具备某种气质。我不知道。
What about injury?
Are you worried about injury?
I'm worried any time I get active, like you're going to blow out a hamstring or a lower back.
I mean, you know, we're not 25 anymore.
Yeah, but were you ever like that before, or is it age that's telling you that?
Or bringing that fear?
You're sneak.
J.B. not sneaky.
那受伤呢？你担心受伤吗？只要我一活动，我就担心受伤，比如拉伤腿筋或下背部。我是说，你知道，我们不再是 25 岁了。对，但你以前也这样吗，还是说这是年龄在提醒你？或者带来了这种恐惧？你真狡猾。J.B. 一点也不狡猾。
He's very athletic.
I will say, I've seen him hit a softball out of the park,
and he's a heck of a golfer.
But he does pull a muscle now,
you know, pulling Greek yogurt out of the fridge.
Yeah.
You know, it starts to wear on you after a while.
But anyway.
他很有运动天赋。我得说，我见过他把垒球击出球场，他是个高尔夫球高手。但他现在确实会拉伤肌肉，你知道，比如从冰箱里拿希腊酸奶的时候。对。你知道，时间长了身体就开始吃不消了。不过话说回来。
No, I don't worry about it.
I don't worry about it.
I have injured myself,
and it just means you have to sit for a while, you know.
But you're not legging out ground balls,
Are you?
Oh, no.
Yeah.
不，我不担心。我不担心。我受过伤，那只意味着你必须坐下来休息一会儿，你知道的。但你不会去拼尽全力跑内野高飞球，对吧？哦，不会。对。
I went the last time I played Chelsea peers of, sorry, go ahead, Tim.
No, I was going to say, yeah, I leg them out as fast as I can.
Right.
But I'm not, you know, going to tear a muscle for it.
Have you guys ever tried to not say when you're talking over each other and someone says, go ahead?
Have you ever tried not to say?
Oh, yeah, no, I was just going to say.
对。我上次在切尔西码头打球的时候……抱歉，你先说，蒂姆。不，我要说的是，对，我尽可能快地拼尽全力跑。没错。但我不会，你知道的，为此去撕裂肌肉。你们有没有试过在互相插话时不说那句话，当有人说“你先请”的时候？你们有没有试过不说？哦，对，不，我正要说。
Yeah.
You can't, you can't do it.
Not, yeah.
Oh, that's right.
If somebody, if somebody says go ahead, you, you don't just go ahead.
It's always a, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, I was just going to say, you can't, I'm telling you, try, try to do a week without that.
You can't do it.
It doesn't work with an edit, either.
对。你做不到，你做不到。不，对。哦，对了。如果有人，如果有人说你先请，你，你不能直接就先请了。总会有一个，对，对，对，不，我正要说，你做不到，我跟你说，试着一周不这样。你做不到。这在剪辑里也没用。
It's true.
Like, if they edit out the interruption.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
It doesn't work with the edit.
You know, I've been curious about this, you know, I've listened to this show, and I love it.
And, um, has it ever gone wrong?
Oh, yeah.
确实。比如，如果他们把打断的话剪掉。对，没错。对。剪辑后根本行不通。你知道，我一直对这个很好奇，你知道，我听过这个节目，我很喜欢它。而且，呃，它有没有翻车过？哦，会。
Like when you, like the surprise guest is actually someone that's the one of the other two hate or has had a bad relationship with or a, or some kind of.
Yes.
You don't have to say names.
Don't have to say names.
Well, I tell you what, Tim, it's funny you ask, because I got it, not in trouble, but about six months ago, guys, I was doing, I did this guy's podcast in the UK, this really funny dude, Romas.
He's hilarious dude.
And I mentioned that a couple of,
that we'd had a couple of guests that didn't go so great.
比如当你，比如惊喜嘉宾实际上是另外两个人中的一个讨厌的人，或者有过糟糕的关系，或者某种。是的。你不用说名字。不用说名字。好吧，我告诉你，蒂姆，你这么问很有意思，因为我惹上了，不是麻烦，但大约六个月前，伙计们，我在做，我在英国做这个家伙的播客，一个非常有趣的家伙，罗马斯。他是个搞笑的家伙。我提到过几次，我们曾有过几个嘉宾效果不太好。
And everybody I knew asked you guys, right?
And asked me who I was talking.
I didn't say who.
But we had a couple that didn't go so shit hot.
Give us the names now, Will.
It's just us.
But we have had, yeah, and you have, as you know, I mean, it's,
we all kind of are in, we do the same.
然后我认识的每个人都问你们，对吧？还问我到底在说谁。我没说名字。但我们确实有几个嘉宾效果没那么操蛋。威尔，现在把名字给我们吧。就我们几个。但我们确实有，是的，正如你所知，我的意思是，我们都在，我们都做同样的事。
And we work with a lot of people, and we know a lot of people,
and we know, and there's a lot of crossover,
and there are certainly times where you have people who, they're a hurt feeling,
or whatever, and there are times where you have people on who you're like,
yeah, I got history with this person.
But it's never, but it's never gone wrong, like, the reason that episodes have not aired
is not because there was anything contentious or something like that.
It's more just like, that was sort of like not really a flowing interview and probably,
而且我们和很多人合作，我们认识很多人，我们知道，这里面有很多交集，当然也有某些时候，你会遇到这样的人，他们有些被伤害的感情，或者诸如此类的事，也有某些时候，你会请来这样的人，让你觉得，是的，我和这个人有历史。但它从来，但它从来没有彻底搞砸过，比如，节目没有播出的原因并不是因为有什么针锋相对的事情之类的。更多是因为，那感觉就像不是一次很流畅的采访，可能，
and just to protect the guest mostly.
It's like, they don't need that out there, you know,
where they were sort of,
tight or we were tight and it's just not an entertaining thing and so we just we scrap it we do we do so
many and and we also i think um sorry i was uh demanding to say yes yes that um
that um that we always once we get on i think that i i you guys chime in too that we want
i always want it to go well like i want it to go i'm always rooting for the person no matter who it is i
want it to be good.
而且主要是为了保护嘉宾。这就像是，他们不需要把那一面暴露出去，你知道的，他们当时有点拘束，或者我们很拘束，这根本不是一个有趣的节目，所以我们直接取消了它，我们做了这么多，而且我也觉得，抱歉，我刚刚，我不得不说是的，是的，那个，那个，那个，我们一旦开始录制，我想你们也会加入进来，就是我们希望，我总是希望一切顺利，就像我希望它进展顺利，无论他是谁，我总是支持这个人，我希望它是精彩的。
Yeah.
Always is.
Yeah, I just was, I was curious about, like, like, two of you don't know who the next
guest is going to be.
Right.
Correct.
Yeah.
So what if, like, you had an affair with somebody?
对。一直都是。对，我只是，我只是很好奇，比如，比如，你们两个不知道下一个嘉宾会是谁。对。没错。所以如果，比如，你和某个人有过一段情。
That was previously undisclosed.
And it ended poorly.
Yeah.
Guess what?
We're way too close.
We know each other's dead bodies and everything.
So when there is somebody that we know the other person has mentioned before as
maybe not being their favorite person,
那是以前没有公开过的。而且结局很糟糕。对。猜怎么着？我们太亲近了。我们连对方的死相都知道得一清二楚。所以当有这样一个人，我们知道另一个人以前曾提到过他可能不是自己最喜欢的人时，
we will sort of break our little rule and say,
hey, man, I was thinking about having such and such on.
Are you guys good?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't tell you when, but yeah.
We don't say when, and people do ask,
we legit, the other two legit don't know
who the other person is going to be on that day.
我们会稍微打破一下我们的小规则，说：“嘿，老兄，我考虑请某某某来。你们觉得行吗？”对，对。我不会告诉你什么时候，但是是的。我们不说什么时候，如果人们问起，我们是认真的，另外两个人真的不知道那天来的人会是谁。
So there is, as J.B. says,
there might be like down the road, like, hey,
but we never let it.
I like that element of surprise about it.
Yeah.
I think that's a good thing.
Well, what's funny is, and we know this,
is the audience knows who's on because we advertise who the upcoming guest is.
所以正如 J.B. 所说，以后可能会有，比如，嘿，但我们绝不会让它……我很喜欢那种惊喜的元素。对。我觉得这是一件好事。好吧，有趣的是，我们都知道，观众知道谁会来，因为我们会提前宣传接下来的嘉宾是谁。
So we're the only two idiots at don't know.
It's just for us, I guess.
It's just to save the homework.
Right.
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
Tim, so let's, so I mentioned Bill Dorman, you auditioned for that.
And talk a little bit about, so you grew up, you, I mean, your parents were musicians, right?
所以我们是仅有的两个不知道的傻瓜。我想这只是针对我们自己的。这只是为了省得做功课。没错。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。蒂姆，那么我们，我提到了《惊爆点》，你去试镜了。聊聊，那么你长大了，你，我的意思是，你的父母是音乐家，对吧？
You grew up in the city.
Really?
Yeah.
And your folks were musicians.
And so when did you know that you, well,
weren't going to go in the family business necessarily be a musician
and that you were going to go and but you were going to perform, you know, as an actor?
I probably got the bug from watching my dad on stage with his group, the highwayman.
你在城里长大。真的吗？对。你的父母是音乐家。那么你是从什么时候知道自己，好吧，不一定会继承家族事业当音乐家，而是要去，但是你要去表演，你知道的，作为一个演员？我大概是从看我爸爸和他的乐队“高速公路人”在舞台上的演出中得到了启发。
He was a folk musician.
And I remember specifically, not very clearly, but a responding,
the audience responding to him saying something and laughing.
I felt that was like the entry point.
That was the moment my three-year-old or four-year-old self was like,
hmm, I want that.
So he became, you know, he went out on the road until 1965 with them.
And they made several albums together.
他是个民谣音乐家。我记得很清楚，虽然不是非常清晰，但观众对他说的话作出了反应并笑了。我觉得那是进入这个领域的入口。那就是我三四岁的自己心里想的：嗯，我想要那个。所以他成为了，你知道的，他一直和他们一起巡演到 1965 年。他们一起录制了几张专辑。
I had the music bug, though, too, as well.
Acting, I started in grade school, but music I also had it.
And I actually, I'm glad you bring that up because I've been working the past couple
weeks on some mixes of some concerts I've done.
I have a band called the Rokes Gallery Band.
Wow.
Really?
And we occasionally will perform live.
不过我身上也有音乐的细胞。演戏，我是从小学开始的，但音乐我也很有天赋。而且实际上，我很高兴你提起这个，因为过去几周我一直在处理我做过的一些演唱会的混音。我有一个乐队叫 Rokes Gallery 乐队。哇。真的吗？我们偶尔会进行现场演出。
We've done tours of Europe and the United States.
And we recorded several of those shows.
So I'm mixing a couple of them right now.
I'm opening a kind of new website,
performance kind of platformware.
What's the website?
It's Timrobbins.com.
Okay.
我们在欧洲和美国进行过巡演。我们录制了其中的几场演出。所以我现在正在混音其中的几场。我正在开辟一个全新的网站，一种表演类的平台软件。网站叫什么？是 Timrobbins.com。好吧。
And it'll be launching.
How did you come up with the name?
I fed it through an AI computer to tell me what would be the best available.
Do you play guitar and sing?
I play guitar and sing, and I write most of the songs.
We do some covers, but usually covers that are really not well-known songs.
The Rokes Gallery started as a band put together by Hal Wilner.
and it was
它即将上线。你是怎么想出这个名字的？我把它输入到人工智能电脑里，让它告诉我什么会是最佳可用选项。你会弹吉他和唱歌吗？我弹吉他唱歌，大部分歌都是我写的。我们也翻唱一些，但通常是那些很不为人知的歌曲。Rokes Gallery 最初是由哈尔·威尔纳（Hal Wilner）组建的一个乐队，它是
originally the albums they made
were about sea shanties
with, you know, all kinds of different guests,
guest artists,
and Hal was, you know,
such a genius,
and one of the angels in my life,
you know, he used to work at Saturday Night Live.
最初制作的专辑是关于海员号子的，你知道，有各种各样的客座艺术家，哈尔是，你知道的，如此天才，是我生命中的天使之一，你知道的，他以前在《周六夜现场》工作。
Yeah, I was going to say, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, not well, but I knew him a little bit, yeah.
Yeah, and so,
I'm on this new site.
I don't want to call it a website because it's sort of like...
It's a destination.
It's an experience.
Yeah.
对，我正要说，是的。对，对，不是很熟，但我多少认识他一点，是的。对，所以，我在这个新网站上。我不想叫它网站，因为它有点像……它是一个目的地。它是一种体验。对。
Whatever.
It's right.
Portal.
It's a portal.
Basically, it's my way of like...
My portal.
That's good.
Portal.
随便吧。没错。传送门。它是一个传送门。基本上，这就是我的一种方式……我的传送门。这不错。传送门。
It's portal.
Tim Robbins portal.
I have a storage unit that I have so much stuff in.
And I want to get rid of.
That's what they're for.
So I was looking through some boxes in there,
and I found some old videotapes of...
I used to mess around on sets with old-school video camera.
这就是传送门。蒂姆·罗宾斯传送门。我有一个储物单元，里面堆了好多东西。我想把它们清理掉。那正是它们的用处。所以我翻了翻里面的几个箱子，我找到了一些老旧的录像带……我以前在片场用老式摄像机瞎胡闹。
You know, the ones where you could load the entire video cassette in.
Yeah, the VHS thing.
Sure.
You'd shoot, like, behind-the-scenes stuff of projects you were on?
Yeah, but it would be more like stories that I was making up, right?
I have one from Howard the Duck.
Yeah, and so I made up a story about, you know,
what was this intrigue that was happening on the set of Howard the Duck.
你知道的，那种可以把整盒录像带塞进去的。对，VHS 那种。没错。你会拍摄你参与的项目幕后的花絮吗？对，但更像是编造一些故事，你知道吗？我有一个关于《霍华德鸭》的。对，所以我编了一个故事，你知道，在《霍华德鸭》的片场到底发生了什么阴谋诡异的事。
And I did two with Howard the Duck.
I did one that was about this actor that goes to set and everybody hates.
And the other was about this place called Kittyland that we were
filming at. It was this location
we kept going back to because
there was always a shot that they needed
and so you thought you were finished
with Kitty Lanin and it would not
我拍了两个关于《霍华德鸭》的。一个是关于一个去片场结果遭到所有人讨厌的演员。另一个是关于我们拍摄的一个叫“小猫乐园”（Kittyland）的地方。那是我们一直回去的一个外景地，因为总有一个他们需要的镜头，所以你以为你拍完小猫乐园了，结果它根本
it would not end. I was on that movie
for six months.
It was supposed to be three.
And the last six weeks of it
were the ultralight sequence, which
is like maybe five minutes in the film.
So it was
pretty extraordinary, so I was going
没完没了。我在那部电影里呆了六个月。本来应该是三个月。最后六 weeks 是超轻型飞机序列，在电影里大概只有五分钟。所以这相当不寻常，所以我有点
a little crazy and so I had
this video camera and I had
friendships with the crew members
and we would, you know, just make
shit up. So you sat there and you were
watching this video after
going through your storage unit and like...
Yeah, so I said, I want to put that out there.
快疯了，所以我就拿着这个摄像机，我和剧组成员关系很好，我们就会，你知道的，瞎编乱造。所以你坐在那里，在整理完储物单元后看着这段录像，然后……对，所以我说，我想把它放出来。
I think people would like
this. I also have all these interviews
with people like, you know,
Johnny Cash and Kurt Vonnegut and
Harry Belafonte and
I, you know, I've never released them.
Wow. Did you remember these?
Or did they just come back to you as you were going
我觉得大家会喜欢这个。我还保留着所有这些对一些人的采访，你知道的，比如约翰·卡西迪、库尔特·冯内古特和哈里·贝拉方特，我，你知道的，我从来没有公开发布过。哇。你还记得这些吗？还是说当你翻看储物单元，开始看到所有这些磁带时，它们才浮现在脑海中？你有没有坐下来，度过一个充满回忆杀的周末？那一定挺有震撼力的，那些回忆之旅既有震撼力也很危险，对吧，我们过去的版本。
through the storage unit and you started seeing all these tapes did you sit down and have like a
weekend of going down memory lane that must have been really kind of powerful those those journeys can be
powerful and dangerous too right old versions of ourselves i know and what it means and what did i what was
i thinking and so you have to give a listen and make sure that you weren't an idiot at the time that
you were doing this um but i think there's some good stuff here and and the people that have been
working with me are, you know, they're the ones kind of driving.
They were like, why aren't you doing anything with this stuff?
So these are up on Tim Robbins.com or you're in the process of doing that?
我知道，这意味着什么，我当时在想什么？所以你必须听一听，确保你当时没有像个白痴一样，但我觉得这里面有些好东西，而且一直和我合作的人，你知道的，他们才是某种程度上推动这一切的人。他们说，你为什么不拿这些东西做点什么呢？所以这些会放到 TimRobbins.com 上，还是你正在筹备中？
No, it won't be up until September 1st.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
But that's like a visual, you know, people say, you know, you should write a book, you know,
but like this sounds like a kind of like a visual book.
I mean, it's really cool.
It's multimedia.
It is.
不，要到 9 月 1 号才会上线。哦，好吧。对。但这就像是一个视觉，你知道的，人们常说，你应该写本书，你知道的，但这听起来像是一种视觉上的书。我的意思是，这真的很酷。这是多媒体的。确实。
It's a portal.
Exactly.
It's a portal for everything.
This is my marketing team.
All right.
What else do we call?
I've got this thing called Robbins Radio,
which is going to be on my live shows,
它是一个传送门。没错。这是一个万能传送门。这是我的营销团队。好吧。我们还叫什么？我有个叫罗宾斯广播（Robbins Radio）的东西，里面会有我的现场演出，
my father's shows,
and my brother, who is a film composer, his scores.
And it'll be, you know, kind of on a kind of random play.
Yeah.
Continuous when you come to the website.
Dude, that's cool.
Yeah, I'm excited by it.
It is like a living archive.
我父亲的演出，还有我弟弟的配乐，他是一位电影作曲家。它会，你知道的，在某种程度上随机播放。对。当你来到网站时它会持续播放。老兄，这太酷了。对，我对它很兴奋。这就像一个活生生的档案。
I'm this, but it's also just,
it's also just been a lot of fun to do.
Yeah.
And at the same time, I am actually writing a memoir.
So it's, it's all just coalescing.
And I'm trying to find stuff that might be interesting.
Do you have a name for the memoir yet?
No, I don't.
我是这样想的，但同时，这也是一件非常有趣的事。对。与此同时，我其实正在写一本回忆录。所以这一切都在融合。我正在试图找出可能有趣的事情。你给这本回忆录起好名字了吗？还没有，没有。
Say timrobots.com.
No, portal.
Timrobons.
Timrobons.com speaks.
On paper.
Yeah.
Now, Tim, you used.
You used music in, I was just thinking about, sorry, Sean, I was just going to say.
叫 timrobots.com。不，传送门。Timrobons。Timrobons.com 发声。纸质版。对。现在，蒂姆，你用过。你在……中用过音乐，我刚才在想，抱歉，肖恩，我正要说。
The Times of Tim Robbins.com.
Yeah, oh, that's good.
Oh, that's really good.
And it'll drive people to the website.
They'll buy the book, and the website's right there on the cover.
By the way, you open the book, and it's just a hyperlink to the website.
It's a QR code.
It's a one page.
Tim Robbins.com 的时代。对，哦，那挺好。哦，这真的很好。这会把人们吸引到网站上去。他们会买书，而网站就在封面正中央。顺便说一句，你打开这本书，里面就是一个指向网站的超链接。它是一个二维码。它只有一页。
Oh, my God, it's so good.
Oh, you'd be so cheap to make.
The publisher would be stoked.
Do you think you, I was just thinking about,
You're thinking about your dad and the highwaymen.
Now, wait, the highwayman, wasn't that Bob Dylan?
No, that was, no, I think you're thinking of the Johnny Cash, Whalen Jennings,
hireman.
哦，天哪，太棒了。哦，制作成本会极其低廉。出版商一定会兴奋死的。你觉得你，我刚才在想，你在想你父亲和“高速公路人”。等等，“高速公路人”，那不是鲍勃·迪伦吗？不，那是，不，我想你想到的是约翰尼·卡什、韦伦·詹宁斯那个“高速公路人”。
Willie Nelson might have been.
And that's not it?
No, this was in the early 60s.
Okay.
Before your time.
Sure.
Barely.
It was, yeah, 1960 to 65 were their years.
威利·纳尔逊可能也是。那不是吗？不，这是在 60 年代初。好吧。在你出生之前。当然。勉强算吧。那是，对，1960 到 1965 年是他们的时代。
But you took, you took, I was thinking about the, I think the first film you directed was
Bob Roberts, right? Am I right?
Yes. And that was
about a guy, which is a great movie
about a guy who
is like a right-wing politician, but he
uses folk music to kind of sell
what he's doing. And it was
但你用了，我刚才在想，我想你导演的第一部电影是《鲍勃·罗伯茨》，对吧？我没记错吧？是的。那是关于一个人的，这是一部很棒的电影，讲的是一个右翼政客，但他用民歌来推销他所做的事情，而且
like a confluence of, this guy
kind of used media and
personality and, and if in a lot of ways
it was very sort of prescient, if you
think about it, of considering where we
are these days. Unfortunately. I mean, it was a little
Yeah. Yeah. I mean
is pretty
就像是，这个家伙以某种方式运用了媒体和个性，而且在很多方面都非常有先见之明，如果你想想的话，考虑到我们今天所处的位置。不幸的是。我的意思是，这有点……对。对。我的意思是，非常……
can you
do you ever think
have you thought back on that
over these last years and gone like wow
we were
we kind of predicted the way
politics might go in terms of
the celebrity aspect of it
你可以，你有没有想过？在过去这些年里，你有没有回想过那部电影，然后觉得，哇，我们在政治的发展方向上，在名流化这一方面，我们某种程度上进行过预言？
yeah you know it's
yes it's weird
but it's also
I was looking you know
going through all this stuff
realizing that at the time
when I was doing press for it
I was also
是的，你知道，是的，这很奇怪，但我也在看，你知道，在浏览所有这些东西时意识到，当时我在为它做宣传时，我也在
in some of the interviews
they were saying
is this, you know, is this
because the coming election
was George Bush
senior versus Clinton
when it came out.
And so the press was asking,
在一些采访中，他们说，这是，你知道，这是因为即将到来的选举是老布什对阵克林顿，当时电影上映了。所以记者们在问，
you know, is this movie about Bush?
And I said, well, he's actually
in the film, you know, there's
clips of him in the film.
But it also could be about
you know, the Gore of a doll character
too, you know, it could be about
what, why
你知道，这部电影是关于布什的吗？我说，好吧，他其实就在电影里，你知道，电影里有他的剪辑片段。但它也可以是关于，你知道的，戈尔或者多尔那个角色的，你知道，它也可以是关于为什么
change doesn't happen.
And so when Bill Clinton was playing his saxophone on a Sydney Hall,
I was like, hmm, that's kind of Bob Robertsy too.
Yeah.
So at the time, I said, you know, it could be either.
I don't know.
I don't, I really don't know.
So as time has gone on, it's become kind of, you know,
变革不会发生。所以当比尔·克林顿在某个大厅里吹萨克斯时，我在想，嗯，那也挺有《鲍勃·罗伯茨》的感觉的。对。所以在当时，我说，你知道，两边都可能。我不知道。我不知道，我真的不知道。所以随着时间的推移，它在某种程度上已经变得，你知道的，
very prescient as far as the current administration.
but I personally am not a happy guy with either.
I got to say there's got to be better ideas and better, you know,
better motivation for people to vote for Democrats.
They have to get their stuff together.
They really do.
Yeah, I think there's a lot of shortcomings.
No shortage of shortcomings.
就现任政府而言，非常有先见之明。但我个人对这两者都不高兴。我得说，必须有更好的想法，更好的，你知道，更好的动机让人们投票给民主党。他们必须把事情搞定。他们真的必须如此。对，我觉得有很多缺点。缺点绝对不缺。
I've learned, at 65, you know what I did is I realized I have to retire from something, right?
I didn't want to stop acting.
I didn't want to stop directing or writing.
So what I retired from was the daily anxiety of opposing something.
Oh, that's good.
The idea that you can find your worth and purpose and virtue by hatred is a terrible, terrible idea.
And the idea that the source of your hatred is a particular,
person you don't know, it's even a worse idea. You're battling a concept or an idea or a philosophy.
我懂得了，到了 65 岁，你知道我做了什么，我意识到我必须从某些事情中退休，对吧？我不想停止演戏。我不想停止导演或写作。所以我退休的事情是反对某事的日常焦虑。哦，那太好了。那种认为你可以通过仇恨找到自己的价值、目的和美德的想法，是一个糟糕透顶的想法。而那种认为你的仇恨之源是一个你并不认识的特定个人的想法，则更是一个糟糕的想法。你是在与一个概念、一个想法或一种哲学作斗争。
You're not dealing with an individual. Right. And so there's so, I feel like there's too many people
that wake up agitated about political figures. And then they use that as a fuel to get through the day.
That's so true. On either side. And it's not a good way to start your day. The first thing you're doing is doom scrolling about
something that will make you feel better
about your political beliefs
you know you might try
a little yoga or you might try
a little exercise or take a bike ride
你不是在和一个个人打交道。没错。所以我觉得有太多人醒来时对政治人物感到愤怒。然后他们把这作为度过一天的动力。确实如此。双方都是。这不是开始一天的好的方式。你做的第一件事就是疯狂刷手机看那些能让你对自己的政治信仰感觉好一点的内容，你知道的，你或许可以试着练练瑜伽，或者试着锻炼一下，或者骑自行车
or totally because I always say that
I have this discussion with Scotty all the time you can watch it
all day long on TV or read about it online or
whatever but there's nothing you can
do about it necessarily
we have the power to vote
and we have the power to
protest but to actually
完全赞同，因为我总是说，我和斯科蒂经常讨论这个，你可以在电视上看一整天，或者在网上阅读相关内容之类的，但你对此实际上无能为力，我们有投票的权力，我们有抗议的权力，但实际上
you know my friend Maria Shriver
she always one of the greatest quotes ever
And if anybody's complaining about any of it, she goes,
I totally agree, so what are you doing about it?
Yeah.
And it stops people in their tracks.
Well, here's the thing.
This is what I learned was that what are you doing about it?
你知道我的朋友玛丽亚·施赖弗，她总是说出史上最棒的名言之一。如果有人在抱怨这些事，她会说，我完全同意，所以你为此做了什么？是的。这让人们当场语塞。好吧，事情是这样的。这就是我学到的，那就是你为此做了什么？
Well, about 15 years ago, I had that epiphany of like, what are you doing about it?
And I started working in spaces where I could make a difference.
So with my nonprofit, with the actors gang.
So I put a lot of attention into how can I expand the programs that we have,
the education programs that we go into schools that do not have theater programs,
and we introduce them to theater.
The prison project that we have that goes into California State prisons.
What is that?
嗯，大约15周年，我有了那种顿悟，就像是，你为此做了什么？我开始在能发挥作用的领域工作。比如在我的非营利组织，在演员帮。所以我把很多注意力放在如何扩大我们的项目上，包括我们进入那些没有戏剧项目的学校的教育项目，我们将戏剧介绍给他们。我们在加州州立监狱开展的监狱项目。那是什么？
It's a rehabilitation program that we've been doing for 20 years now.
Through like theater and acting and stuff like that?
It's basically, I made a documentary about it, actually.
I know, that's why I asked.
I feel like I saw it.
It's called 45 seconds of laughter, and it will be coming to criterion in November.
Oh, then I saw something else.
Yeah.
这是一个我们已经做了20年的康复项目。通过戏剧和表演之类的方式？基本上是这样的，实际上我为此拍了一部纪录片。我知道，这就是我问的原因。我觉得我看过。它叫《45秒的笑声》，11月份将在标准收藏（Criterion）上映。哦，那我看到的是别的。是的。
You may have seen it.
We've screened it around.
It went to the Venice Film Festival and to New York Film Festival.
No, what we do is we don't go in, as some groups do, and I think that's valid, too,
but we don't go in to do a production.
We don't, you know, try to make a production.
What we do is we do a seven-day intensive workshop to train them,
which is basically in the four states of emotion that we have.
你可能看过。我们到处放映过。它去过威尼斯电影节和纽约电影节。不，我们做的是，我们不会像某些团体那样进去做一部制作，我认为那也有其价值，但我们不是为了做一部制作而进去。我们做的是，我们进行为期七天的强化工作坊来训练他们，主要训练我们拥有的四种情绪状态。
And we introduce these states of emotion,
but first we introduce the characters they will be playing them in.
So we create a distance between their expression of emotion
and their personal story.
So we use the Comedie de Larte.
So you have the rich old man who wants to marry off his,
beautiful daughter who's in love with a young man.
He wants to marry her off to one of his business associates.
我们引入这些情绪状态，但首先我们引入他们将要扮演的角色。因此，我们在他们的情感表达和他们的个人故事之间创造了一段距离。所以我们使用即兴喜剧（Commedia dell'arte）。所以你有一个富有的老头，他想把年轻貌美、与一个年轻男子相爱的女儿嫁出去。他想把她嫁给他的一个商业伙伴。
It's a tale as old as the time.
It's done in every culture.
It's told in every culture.
I saw it in Bali in a town square.
But the reason is it keeps the characters simple and stock kind of characters.
And then we try to get them to genuinely
portray emotions through these characters.
Wow.
这是一个自古以来都有的故事。每种文化中都有。每个文化都在讲述它。我在巴厘岛的一个小镇广场上见过。但原因在于它让角色保持简单和类型化。然后我们试图让他们通过这些角色真诚地表现出情感。哇。
So what happens is they get in touch with emotions
that they have kept dormant or suppressed
for many, many years.
Survival in prison is one emotion, it's anger.
It's about keeping safe on the yard.
You have to project an image of anger.
And so when they start playing these other emotions,
some of them tell us that they haven't been allowed
所以发生的事情是，他们接触到了那些被他们沉睡或压抑了多年、许多年的情感。监狱里的生存是一种情感，那就是愤怒。这是为了在院子里保持安全。你必须展现出一个愤怒的形象。所以当他们开始扮演这些其他的情感时，他们中的一些人告诉我们，他们已经好几年不被允许
to be sad or, you know,
in fear or happy for years.
And so it allows them in this place.
The other great thing about it is when we set a program up,
we ask the prison to give us people from different sections.
Like it has to be integrated with different gangs, different, you know,
so they're all in the same room.
And what we find out happening is this bond that happens in a room
去悲伤，或者，你知道的，去体验恐惧或快乐了。所以这个地方允许他们这样做。关于它的另一个伟大之处是，当我们设立一个项目时，我们要求监狱给我们不同区域的人。比如它必须融合不同的帮派，不同的，你知道的，所以他们都在同一个房间里。我们发现发生的事情是，在这个房间里
between them when they're sharing emotions together.
and looking in each other's eyes
and realizing that they have a lot more in common.
I mean, imagine if we could do that for people who aren't in prison.
That's what sent me on this path of like,
if these guys can do it, we can do it.
You know, we can't, we don't, we have created our own yard
where you have segmented populations that stick together
当他们一起分享情感时，他们之间产生了一种纽带。看着彼此的眼睛，意识到他们有更多的共同点。我的意思是，想象一下，如果我们能为那些不在监狱里的人做到这一点。这就是把我带上这条路的动力，如果这些家伙能做到，我们也能做到。你知道，我们不能，我们没有，我们创造了自己的院子，在那里你有割裂的人群，他们抱团取暖
and if anyone crosses over the line,
it's at their own, you know, detriment.
Right.
And that's the way it is now in our society.
If you say anything that might be sympathetic to what you view is the other side.
Yeah.
You're done.
如果有人越界，那是他们自找的，你知道的，自讨苦吃。没错。而这正是我们现在社会中的现状。没错。如果你说任何可能对你视为对立面的人表示同情的话。是的。你就完了。
You're out.
You're done.
You're condemned.
And it's, listen, it's a terrible way to build a movement.
Let's just put it that way.
When a good organizer walks into a room to organize a movement,
they have the main objective is to find out what all these different people have in common
right there's going to be they have to walk in knowing they're not all going to agree with them so
你出局了。你完了。你被谴责了。听着，这是一种建立运动的糟糕方式。我们这么说吧。当一个优秀的组织者走进一个房间去组织一场运动时，他们的主要目标是找出所有这些不同的人有什么共同点，现场就会有，他们必须带着这样的认知走进去：并不是所有人都会同意他们的观点，所以
what can we agree on right it seems like the opposite now it seems like in order to get to save
your position in a certain community you have to act in a certain way and if you act outside of that
then you're kicked out of the community.
Yeah, that's right.
And that's on both sides, by the way.
That's not a partisan thing.
That's something that happens on both sides.
And that's not a good way to build a movement.
我们能达成什么共识？现在情况似乎恰好相反，似乎为了在某个社群中保住你的地位，你必须以某种特定的方式行事，如果你越轨了，那么你就会被踢出这个社群。是的，确实如此。顺便说一句，双方都是这样。这不是党派问题。这是双方都会发生的事情。这不是建立运动的好方法。
I totally agree.
Because basically you're making people,
you're saying you have to agree with me or you're done.
And then so people learn very quickly,
oh, well, I shouldn't talk.
I shouldn't say anything.
I won't say anything.
Even though I don't agree with what they're saying,
我完全同意。因为基本上你在强迫人们，你在说你必须同意我，否则你就完了。然后人们很快就会学到，哦，好吧，我不该说话。我不应该说任何话。我什么都不会说。尽管我不同意他们的话，
I'm not going to say it.
And so that's not an alliance.
That's fear that's causing that.
Right.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
Tim, did you get involved in the prison stuff when you did,
because I was thinking about Dead Man Walking,
我也不会说出来。所以这不是结盟。是恐惧造成了这种结果。没错。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。蒂姆，你参与监狱项目是因为，因为我在想《死囚漫步》，
which is your second film,
which is so different from Bob Roberts in every way.
Is that when you first started getting involved with that
or becoming really aware of that?
I was kind of aware of a girl.
Growing up, I had friends that went to jail, so it wasn't, it was one of those, you know,
there for the grace of God go I, you know, I had maybe different parents or different
upbringing that kept me away from that.
这是你的第二部电影，它在各方面都和《鲍勃·罗伯茨》截然不同。那是你第一次开始参与其中，或者真正意识到这一点的时候吗？我多少了解一点。在成长过程中，我有些朋友进了监狱，所以这不是……那是一种“若非神恩，我就身陷其中”的情况，你知道的，我可能有不同的父母或不同的成长环境，让我远离了那种生活。
But, and then I did some work with some prison organizations back in New York when I first,
you know, after Bull Durham.
But then I did Shawshank and then, then Deadman Walking.
So I was around that space more and more.
And one of the things I, you know, one of the prison guards on Shawshank said to me was, you know, I asked what would you do to change things if you could, you know.
And these are salt of the earth, Republican, conservative, Ohio kind of prison guards.
and the guy said, you know, you've got to legalize drugs
because what we have is we have people coming in for possession for a year
但是，后来我在纽约跟一些监狱组织合作过，当我刚开始，你知道的，在《球场尤物》之后。但接着我拍了《肖申克的救赎》，然后是《死囚漫步》。所以我越来越多地接触到这个领域。其中一件事，你知道的，肖申克的一个狱警对我说，你知道的，我问他如果可以的话你会做什么来改变现状，你知道的。而这些都是脚踏实地、共和党、保守派、俄亥俄州那种类型的狱警。那个家伙说，你知道的，你得把毒品合法化，因为我们这里有人因为藏毒被关进来一年
and they're winding up becoming better criminals.
It's basically they call it crime school.
Right.
The prison guards were calling it crime school.
And so basically they said, you know, there's no GED programs,
no job training.
Those are a year waiting list.
So these kids come in and they have to survive with violent offenders
结果他们最后变成了更好的罪犯。这基本上就是他们所说的犯罪学校。没错。狱警们把它叫做犯罪学校。所以基本上他们说，这里没有GED（普通教育发展）项目，没有职业培训。这些都需要排队等待一年。所以这些年轻人进来后必须和暴力违法者一起生存
and they basically are training criminals.
So you've got to either legalize it or create a separate prison.
And did they, since then, there has been movement there, right?
Certainly legalized marijuana to a large extent.
Yes?
Yes.
I don't know if it's that way in Ohio.
Okay.
他们基本上是在训练罪犯。所以你要么把它合法化，要么建立一个独立的监狱。从那以后，那里有所改变吗，对吧？大麻在很大程度上当然合法化了。是吗？是的。我不知道俄亥俄州是不是这样。好吧。
Yeah.
I made a far inferior prison film called Let's Go to Prism.
and Tim, if you ever get a free afternoon.
This is a production. What a feature.
Yeah, and by the way, Tim, I love that you just rattled off those movies that are so huge iconic.
Your friends that were in prison must have watched you in Shawshank and be like,
wait, how did he break out? I got to take something. I've got to figure that out.
Do people, people must still stop you on the street about Shawshank. It is one of the iconic.
对，我拍过一部远不如它的监狱电影叫《狱中日月》。蒂姆，如果你什么时候有空闲的下午。这是一部作品。真是一部故事片。是的，顺便说一句，蒂姆，我喜欢你刚才如数家珍地列出那些如此巨大、标志性的电影。那些坐过牢的朋友一定看过你在《肖申克》里的表现，然后会想，等等，他是怎么逃出去的？我得学点东西。我得弄明白这一点。人们，人们一定还在街上拦住你问关于《肖申克》的事。它是最具标志性的。
I mean, it's always at the top of people's list when people go like, what's your favorite movie?
Shashank's always there.
Yeah, that's a real beautiful thing.
Bull Durham, not right next to it.
Yeah.
I was going to say, I was going to ask you what today you get stopped for mostly
when you go to the story where you're on the public.
I was going to guess Shoshank Redemption or Bulldorm.
我的意思是，当人们列出“你最喜欢的电影是什么”时，它总是名列前茅，《肖申克》总是在上面。是的，这是一件非常美好的事情。相比之下，《球场尤物》就没有那么常被提及了。对。我本想说，我本想问你，现在你走到街上或公共场合时，人们主要因为什么认出你。我本想猜《肖申克的救赎》或《球场尤物》。
But then I was like, but silo, which I watch, and you're fucking brilliant on.
Which, by the way, season three is coming.
I know I can't wait.
Tim, when you showed up on, I had no idea you're in that.
because we're sci-fi nerds, right? Dungeons and Dragons and
everything sci-fi. And I watched it.
Your performance is just incredible in that.
Thank you.
但后来我想，还有《末日地堡》（Silo），我看了，你在里面演得真他妈绝。顺便说一句，第三季要来了。我知道，我等不及了。蒂姆，当你在里面出场时，我完全不知道你在里面。因为我们是科幻迷，对吧？龙与地下城以及所有科幻相关的。我看了。你在里面的表演简直不可思议。谢谢。
Yeah, I really love the show.
Do people stop you now, like nerdy kind of?
Yeah, yes, nerdy and others too.
Yeah, it's a lot of people are seeing it.
It's really nice.
And it's such a good show.
Rebecca Ferguson is a great actor.
是的，我真的很喜欢这部剧。现在人们会拦住你，比如书呆子类型的人吗？是的，是的，书呆子和其他人都有。是的，很多人都在看。这真的很棒。这真的很棒。而且这是一部很好的剧。丽贝卡·弗格森是个伟大的演员。
She's amazing on it.
So good.
I've had a blast on it.
You know, I was shooting over, we were shooting over in London.
So it was, you know, a real human experience, let's put it that way.
Ten hour days, you know, never going over because there's never any weather.
You know, it's always in the silo.
Everything is in the silo.
她在里面的表现太惊艳了。太棒了。我在里面玩得很开心。你知道，我在那边拍戏，我们在伦敦拍戏。所以这是一次，你知道的，真正的跨人类体验，我们这么说吧。每天工作十个小时，你知道的，从来不会超期，因为根本没有天气影响。你知道的，总是在地堡里。一切都在地堡里。
Right, right.
You know, it was, and I actually,
now can talk because this is airing in mid-August.
I've been under like kind of a gag order
shut the hell up kind of thing about the show
because I wasn't supposed to be in season three.
Oh, uh-huh.
It's funny, Sean just ordered a gag,
对，对。你知道的，这曾是，而且我实际上，现在可以谈论了，因为这将在八月中旬播出。我之前一直处于一种类似封口令的状态，要我闭上该死的嘴，关于这部剧，因为我本来不应该出现在第三季里。哦，呃-huh。有趣的是，肖恩刚刚下达了一个封口令，
but that's a different...
Okay.
Also coming in August.
I can't wait.
They're back ordered.
Did you get the ball option too, Sean?
Yeah, of course I did.
但那是另一回事……好吧。八月份也将上映。八月份也将上映。我等不及了。它们断货了。肖恩，你也拿到球形装置选项了吗？对，我当然拿到了。
And I paid extra.
to get it here sooner.
Does that come in
Hello Kitty style?
Of course,
and Dora the Explorer.
What happened?
What was the guy?
我还付了额外费用。为了早点拿到它。那是Hello Kitty风格的吗？当然，还有爱探险的朵拉。怎么了？那家伙是谁？
I just want to say
a little bit more about Sala.
Yeah.
We would,
you know,
the thing about human
is that it allows the crew
to have lives,
我只想多说一点关于《末日地堡》的事。是的。我们会，你知道的，关于人类剧组的事是，它让剧组人员能够拥有生活，
right?
Right.
If you work in 10-hour days,
unrolling lunches,
and everyone knows
they're going to get home
for dinner
with their kids.
对吧？对。如果你每天工作十个小时，不间断地吃午餐，每个人都知道他们可以回家和孩子们吃晚饭。
It creates a happy crew.
Absolutely.
You get people that, you know, the younger people, they have time for a date.
You know, it's not driving you into the ground, you know.
And I really, I was really inspired by that, you know, that's Graham Yose, the executive
producer.
That's his achievement.
He created a great group of people.
这造就了一个快乐的剧组。绝对是的。你会发现人们，你知道的，年轻人，他们有时间去约会。你知道的，它不会把人往死里折磨，你知道的。我真的，我真的深受启发，你知道的，那是格雷厄姆·约斯特（Graham Yost），执行制片人。那是他的成就。他创造了一群很棒的人。
And he created an environment that it wasn't oppressive.
that, you know, we tend to take for granted now.
You know, we're going to go 12, 14, you know, 16 to get the day, you know.
And I've done it as an actor and as a director.
And I never stopped to think, really, until I worked with Clint Eastwood
when we had like six-hour days, seven-hour days.
Like most of the time we were out by lunch.
Wow.
他创造了一个并不压抑的环境。而这，你知道的，我们现在往往把它视为理所当然。你知道的，我们要工作12、14，你知道的，16个小时来完成一天的拍摄，你知道的。我作为演员和导演都这么做过。我从来没有停下来真正思考过，直到我与克林特·伊斯特伍德合作，当时我们每天只工作六小时、七小时。基本上大多数时候我们在午饭前就收工了。哇。
Because he would only do one take on everything.
Wow.
But it created a discipline.
and more family.
It created this idea that we used to have, I think,
in the business of this can be really fun.
Yeah.
What about directing, Tim?
因为他对每场戏都只拍一条。哇。但它建立了一种纪律。以及更多的家庭感。它创造了这种理念，我认为我们以前在这个行业里拥有过，那就是这其实可以非常有趣。是的。关于导演，蒂姆？
Do we get to see some more your great directing anytime soon?
Well, as a matter of fact, yes.
I'm working on what that is on the long term.
Yeah.
I'm writing a couple scripts right now,
which I'm kind of reluctant to James.
Right.
Yeah.
我们不久能看到更多你作为伟大导演的作品吗？嗯，事实上，是的。我正在为此做长期的规划。是的。我现在正在写几个剧本，我对詹姆斯有点保密。对。是的。
Sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'd love to see you write one that you star in and direct about somebody doing what you
were talking about earlier, about, you know, figuring how to not be so sort of tribal with
their beliefs and practices and passions and things like that and trying to be more sort
of inclusive.
And you're the kind of guy that could handle something as, you know, kind of nuanced and
delicate as that.
当然。对，对，对。我很想看你写一部由你主演并执导的电影，讲述某人做你刚才谈到的事情，你知道的，弄清楚如何不对自己的信仰、实践、热情等表现得那么有部落主义色彩，并试图更具包容性。你就是那种能够驾驭像那样细腻微妙题材的人。
Well, thank you.
Yeah.
Where's the conflict?
We need that story.
Well, there could be a bag of money and a gun, you know.
I mean, we'd be...
Perfect.
谢谢。对。冲突在哪里？我们需要这样的故事。冲突在哪里？嗯，可以有一袋钱和一把枪，你知道的。我的意思是，我们会……完美。
We got it.
Yeah, I remember, Tim, I don't know if you remember this.
We probably don't, but everybody asked,
how did you meet Jason, Sean, and Will, how did you guys all meet?
We met playing poker.
I mean, we kind of knew each other before that,
but we really started hanging out when we were playing poker.
完美。我们懂了。是的，我记得，蒂姆，我不知道你还记不记得。你可能不记得了，但每个人都问，你是怎么认识杰森、肖恩和威尔的，你们是怎么认识的？我们是在打扑克时认识的。我的意思是，在此之前我们多少认识彼此，但我们真正开始混在一起是在我们打扑克的时候。
I was like 27, 28, 29,
and you would come over and play poker, too,
sometimes with a at Cage's house.
Yeah, Kyle Gass.
Yes. That was so wild for me who
just got off the boat from Chicago. I'm playing
poker with Tim Rob's like, it was told
all my friends, it was so cool.
我大概27、28、29岁，你有时也会来凯奇（Cage）家打扑克。是的，凯尔·加斯（Kyle Gass）。是的。对于刚从芝加哥初来乍到的我来说，这太疯狂了。我竟然在和蒂姆·罗宾斯打扑克，这太酷了，我把这事告诉了所有的朋友。
I just loved it. It was so wild for me,
but you probably don't remember. I do remember those games.
Yeah, yeah. Yes, absolutely.
But there was an element at cages
that, you know.
Oh, sure.
Yeah. Would lead one to forget.
Yeah. You'd have to crack a window
我太喜欢了。这对我来说太疯狂了，但你可能不记得了。我确实记得那些局。是的，是的。是的，绝对记得。但凯奇家里有个元素，你知道的。哦，当然。是的。
every once in a while.
This dude, for the listeners, should know that this dude had a, in his living room,
was dominated by a custom-made 12-man poker table.
Right.
And he was the bank as well, which...
Served as a kitchen table, the kitchen counter, the dining room.
Sean, one of the first times that you came, Sean came in,
and I think you went all in on like three of your first five hands, and you took a...
会让人忘掉一些事。是的。你得开扇窗户
And then you were like, oh, my God, it's so late.
Remember it was Tuesday nights.
It was often Tuesday.
It was Tuesday night.
You'd be like, oh, I got to go.
And everybody's like, you're not going to.
anywhere.
Right.
每隔一段时间。听众们应该知道，这家伙的客厅里摆着一张定制的12人扑克桌，占据了整个房间的中心。没错。而且他还是庄家，这……它既用作餐桌，又用作厨房中台、饭厅。肖恩，你第一次来的其中一次，肖恩进来了，我想你在前五手牌里有三手都全押了，你拿了一个……
I'm like,
oh,
okay, dumbass.
Like, great.
They want me to stay.
I had a running
Friday night
poker game on Silo.
然后你说，哦，天哪，太晚了。还记得那是周二晚上吗。通常是周二。那是周二晚上。你会说，哦，我得走了。然后每个人都说，你哪儿也不准去。没错。
Oh, really?
And Common was the,
you know,
he was that guy
that walks in and goes,
I've never played this before.
Uh-oh.
Mm-hmm.
我说，哦，好吧，我个笨蛋。太棒了。他们想让我留下来。我在《末日地堡》剧组里组织了一个周五晚上的常驻扑克局。
And all of a sudden,
and by the way,
I don't,
he wasn't bullshitting.
He hadn't.
You know,
he'd be,
and of course,
哦，真的吗？而孔姆（Common）就是那个，你知道的，他走进来会说，“我从来没玩过这个”。哦-oh。嗯-hmm。
the cards are going to drop on him.
Yeah.
And he would win almost every time.
It was insane.
Were you playing Texas Holdham or dealer's choice?
Texas Holden.
Yeah.
God, remember those games?
结果突然之间，顺便说一句，我不知道，他不是在瞎扯。他真的没玩过。你知道的，他会，当然，
Will, how do you remember Tuesdays?
Like, it was Tuesday because I came to the show that night.
I just thought about the same thing as soon as he said that.
Crazy.
It was so, there were a couple people who came in who had first night luck too.
Richter did.
Andy Richter did one time.
And then I remember, remember 80 Miles came in and did the same thing.
牌运会降临在他身上。是的。而且他几乎每次都赢。这太疯狂了。你们玩的是德州扑克还是庄家选择？德州扑克。是的。天哪，还记得那些局吗？
And yeah, I don't know.
No, Tuesday nights.
The Commons went into second and third night.
You know, I won the first week, hands down, right?
And I realized I can't win every week.
I can't do this.
Not a good luck, yeah.
So I kind of was an idiot the second night, and that's when Common won.
威尔，你怎么记得是周二？就像，因为我那天来看演出。他一这么说，我立刻想到了同一件事。太疯狂了。这太……有几个人第一晚来的时候也有新手运。理查德（Richter）就是。安迪·理查德（Andy Richter）有一次也是。然后我记得，记得“80英里”（80 Miles）来的时候也做了同样的事。
And then he went on a string, like three or four and five,
until Rebecca showed up in the last poker game, and she won.
That sounds like fun, man.
First night.
You always shoot in London the whole time, Silo?
Silo, yeah.
Yeah, I was over there for three years.
Really. I mean, back and forth, but a lot of time over in London in the past five years.
是的，我不知道。不，周二晚上。孔姆玩到了第二晚和第三晚。你知道的，第一周我赢了，毫无悬念，对吧？然后我意识到我不能每周都赢。我不能这么做。赢了运气不好，对吧？所以我第二晚表现得像个白痴，那就是孔姆赢的时候。
How do you like living over there?
I loved it.
I loved it. But I'm going to love anywhere I'm living right now.
It's like, why not think that every place you're in is the best place in the world?
Yeah.
Right.
Right. There's so much to do in London.
There's also a lot to complain about.
然后他开启了一连串的连胜，三场、四场、五场，直到丽贝卡在最后一场扑克局出现，然后她赢了。听起来很有趣，老兄。第一晚。你在伦敦拍《末日地堡》时一直都在那边吗？《末日地堡》，是的。是的，我在那边呆了三年。真的。我的意思是，来来回回，但在过去五年里有大量时间在伦敦。
But I was just like, well, how crazy is my life?
How great is my life that I'm being forced to live in London?
one of the world's great cities for like almost three years will will doesn't like it much will's not
a big i love i love i love i love i love i love i love i love i love i want to ask i mean i was just thinking
about this before we let you go tim and jb be kind of for you too a little bit um because i remember
we're working on my thing with bradley i would ask like you guys as actors who are also directors
have such a luxury of working with directors and really good directors um
And we get to do that as actors, but also then to have to do that as director, you get to observe and have that experience with a lot of great directors.
你喜欢住在那里吗？我很喜欢。我很喜欢。但我会喜欢我当下居住的任何地方。这就好比，为什么不认为你所在的每个地方都是世界上最好的地方呢？对。对。伦敦有那么多好玩的事。也有很多可以抱怨的事。
How did working with directors as an actor then influence you as a director?
It must have, right?
Absolutely.
You get it.
Yeah, you know it.
So you know what they're going through.
You know what their process is.
one thing I've also understood is the actor will give you the truth.
但我当时只是想，好吧，我的生活有多疯狂？我的生活有多棒，我竟然被迫住在伦敦，
If you're directing someone and you go in with an idea that you know how the scenes should be played,
that's a bad idea.
Because you're cheating yourself from two really good artists that are going to interpret something.
And oftentimes when they can't say a line or they keep messing up a line,
it means the line needs to be changed.
they're the truth through line.
The director has to modulate their performances
so that it fits into what they're trying to construct.
世界伟大的城市之一，呆了将近三年。威尔，威尔不太喜欢，威尔不太喜欢……我爱，我爱，我爱，我爱，我爱，我爱，我爱，我爱……我想问，我的意思是，在我让你离开之前，蒂姆，我刚才在想这个，JB，这也稍微有点适用于你，嗯……因为我记得我们在和布拉德利合作我的项目时，我会问，像你们这些同时也是导演的演员，有那么多与导演合作的奢侈，而且是很好的导演……
But deep respect for actors
because they're going to tell you a lot
and hopefully they'll tell you in a way
that is not upsetting a set or something.
Hopefully you have a good relationship
and that you can find as much as you can out from them
and then guide it towards what your truth is.
Yeah, it's really well said.
我们作为演员可以做到这一点，但同时作为导演去完成它时，你能够观察并与许多伟大的导演有过这种经历。
The tricky part sometimes is that the director is somewhat obligated.
I would say it's sort of required that they come in with a plan such that everyone who is
obligated to follow them has something to follow and there's a strategy to get the call sheet
done that day and everything.
But oftentimes that plan can be at odds with, like what you're saying, Tim,
about how the actor might have a completely different idea or perspective
or interpretation of what the scene is about
and how it should be played,
作为演员与导演合作的经历，是如何在后来作为导演时影响你的？肯定有影响，对吧？绝对有的。你懂的。是的，你知道。所以你明白他们在经历什么。你知道他们的过程是怎样的。我同样明白的一件事是，演员会给你带来真相。
that could be at odds with some of the plans
for the camera work and whatnot
that have been in effect for months
through prep and tech scouts and all that stuff.
So there's a balance to strike there
that's often somewhat tense
because it's the day you have to shoot it
and there's not a lot of room for reinterpretation.
如果你在指导某人，而你带着一种你知道这场戏应该怎么演的想法进去，那是极其糟糕的想法。因为你剥夺了自己从两个真正优秀的艺术家那里获得某种诠释的机会。很多时候，当他们说不出某句台词或者一直把台词搞砸时，这意味着台词需要修改。他们是真相的主线。导演必须调整他们的表演，使其符合他们试图构建的内容。
Right, that's where you're telling as an actor
when you're directing comes up.
Exactly, to try to talk them into your way.
Yeah, exactly.
Do you guys remember good, do you guys remember moments
where you did a scene,
where you're directing a scene
and an actor did something that so surprised you
但对演员要有深深的敬意，因为他们会告诉你很多信息，希望他们能以一种不会扰乱片场秩序的方式告诉你。希望你们能有良好的关系，你能从他们身上尽可能多地挖掘出东西，然后将其引导向你的真相。是的，这话说的真好。
in the best way that you were like, fuck, yeah.
Yes, absolutely.
Like, mind-blowing stuff sometimes.
You know, it's like, no, it's like,
it's that moment where you go,
we don't have to shoot this scene anymore.
This is done.
This is like, that truth.
棘手的部分有时在于导演多少有些义务。我可以说这几乎是必须的，他们必须带着计划来到片场，这样所有有义务听从他们的人才有所遵循，并且有一套策略来完成当天的通告单等等。但很多时候，这个计划可能与——就像你说的，蒂姆，演员可能对这场戏的主旨以及应该如何表演有着完全不同的想法、视角或诠释——
has been laid down.
Or you don't need coverage of the other actor
because this actor is killing it here.
I'm just going to want to watch them listen and talk.
The guy's like, wait, wait a second,
are you turning around?
You're like, no, we got it.
No, we got it.
这可能会与经过数月的筹备、技术勘景等流程而确定的镜头运用的计划发生冲突。所以在其中要找到一个平衡点，这通常有些紧张，因为那是你必须拍摄的一天，而且没有太多重新诠释的空间。
Oh, man.
Tim, we've taken up way so much of your time.
Man, what a pleasure, dude.
My pleasure.
Yeah, that was very nice of you to come and talk to us.
That pleasure.
Yeah, and Silo Season 3 is happening.
It's on?
没错，正是在这种时候，你作为演员的经验在你执导时就派上用场了。没错，试着说服他们接受你的方式。是的，完全正确。你们还记得吗，好，你们还记得这样的时刻吗：你们在拍一场戏，作为导演，一个演员做出的举动大大超出了你们的预料，
Is it right now?
You may or may not be in it?
Well, now I'm in it.
I wasn't in it until the end of July.
And now we're somewhere in August.
And the truth has been revealed.
I'm actually alive.
And I really love this show.
以一种最棒的方式，让你们觉得，操，太棒了。是的，绝对有。比如，有时候简直是震撼心灵。你知道的，就像，不，就是那种你会说“我们不需要再拍这场戏了，这就完成了”的时刻。这就像，那种真相
I really stand by at 100%.
It's a great, great show, great writers, great actors, great everything.
and crew, everything was so beautiful about it.
I love that at this stage of my career,
I can go to a set and really kind of fall in love again
with people.
In that old way you had when you were young,
you know, you walk on a set and you're like,
已经被奠定了。或者你不需要另一个演员的反打镜头，因为这个演员在这里演得太绝了。我只想看他们倾听和说话。那家伙会说，等等，等等，你要转过镜头吗？你会说，不，我们拍到了。不，我们拍到了。
oh my God, this is the best thing ever.
I felt that about these people on Silo.
I felt it.
That's great.
It was such a great crew.
Well, Silo season three, Tim Robbins.com, it's a multimedia portal.
We've been through that.
Coming September 1st.
哦，天哪。蒂姆，我们占用了你太多时间了。老兄，真是荣幸，老兄。我的荣幸。是的，你能来和我们聊天真是太好了。荣幸之至。是的，而且《末日地堡》第三季正在制作中。已经播出了吗？
Tim, you're just a, you're an icon.
You're the best.
And thanks for the inspirational words today.
Some of those really, really cool stuff.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you, guys.
是现在吗？你可能在里面也可能不在？好吧，我现在在里面了。我直到七月底才在里面。而现在我们大约在八月的某个时候。真相已经大白了。其实我还活着。我真的很喜欢这部剧。
Appreciate it.
Yeah.
All right.
Thanks, dude.
Enjoy your day.
Bye, buddy.
The great Tim Robbins.
Great Tim Robbins.
我百分之百支持它。这是一部非常、非常棒的剧，伟大的编剧，伟大的演员，伟大的一切。还有剧组，关于它的一切都那么美好。我喜欢在我职业生涯的这个阶段，我还能去到一个片场，再次真正爱上人们。带着你年轻时那种老派的方式，你知道的，你走进片场，你会觉得，
the movies he's been in.
I know.
We didn't really talk.
Did you guys see Arlington Road?
Oh, wow.
No, I did not.
I wanted to.
Such a good movie.
哦，天哪，这是有史以来最棒的事。我对《末日地堡》里这些人也有这种感觉。我真的感受到了。太棒了。这是一个如此棒的剧组。好吧，《末日地堡》第三季，TimRobbins.com，这是一个多媒体门户网站。我们已经聊过这个了。9月1日上线。
I don't think I ever saw.
I mean, I haven't seen it such a long time,
but I remember loving that movie.
He plays some, like, psychotic,
or some, it's like a small town
that turns on them or he turns on that.
What about Jacob's Ladder?
Wait, didn't you see it?
9月1日上线。蒂姆，你简直是一个，你是一个偶像。你是最棒的。谢谢你今天带来鼓舞人心的话语。其中有一些真的、真的很酷的东西。谢谢你。是的，是的。谢谢你们，伙计们。
It sounds like you didn't even see it.
I did, and I loved it, but I haven't seen it in decades.
It was so good.
Jacob's Ladder was one of the greatest movies ever.
I have not seen it for years and years and years.
I don't know if it holds up, but man, I thought a few times back then.
And him in War of the World?
Did you see War of the Worlds with Tom Cruise and?
非常感谢。是的。好了。谢谢，老兄。祝你今天过得愉快。再见，老兄。伟大的蒂姆·罗宾斯。伟大的蒂姆·罗宾斯。
Spielberg film, right?
Yeah.
Really good.
He was so good.
Dude, think about the player?
Right.
Remember how groundbreaking that was?
The player was amazing.
他演过的电影。我知道。我们其实没怎么聊。你们看过《 Arlington Road》（ Arlington Road）吗？哦，哇。没有，我没看过。我很想看。真是一部好电影。
What the fuck did we just talk about for an hour?
I know.
Cover any of this shit, for that?
Sorry.
You're going to drive that fucking interview.
No, but he was teaching us stuff about life, man.
Yeah, just open up your mind, Sean.
I love that we're talking about.
我想我从来没看过。我的意思是，我好久没看过这部电影了，但我记得我很喜欢它。他扮演某种，像是精神错乱的人，或者某种，一个小镇反过来对付他们，或者他反过来对付那个……《异度空间》（Jacob's Ladder）呢？等等，你没看过吗？
Who are you mad at?
Yeah, I love that we fan out after he leaves.
I know, I know.
Well, we did it before.
We get shy.
Yeah.
I know, because I'm like, I'm like,
Shawshake Redemption, right?
听起来你甚至都没看。我看过，我很喜欢，但我几十年没看了。太棒了。《异度空间》是有史以来最伟大的电影之一。我已经好几年、好几年、好几年没看过它了。我不知道它经不经得起时间的考验，但天哪，我当年觉得它绝了。还有他在《世界大战》（War of the Worlds）里的表现？你看过汤姆·克鲁斯演的《世界大战》吗？
You remember?
I know. I've seen that movie 100,000 times.
God, is that so good.
And Dead Man Walking.
What is director here is?
By the way, Dead Man Walking.
He's his second film.
I think Sean Penn won the Oscar for that,
斯皮尔伯格的电影，对吧？是的。真的很棒。他演得太好了。老兄，想想《大玩家》（The Player）？没错。还记得那有多开创性吗？《大玩家》太惊艳了。
didn't he?
I think he did.
I remember when my dog had cancer,
and I was taking for his last walk around before we put him down,
I said to his face, I said, it's dead dog walking.
It felt so bad.
And he laughed.
He laughed, didn't he laugh?
我们刚刚他妈的聊了一个小时什么？我知道。讨论这些破事，就为了这个？抱歉。你要去主导那个该死的采访。不，但他是在教我们关于生活的道理，老兄。是的，放开你的思维，肖恩。我喜欢我们讨论这个。
Oh, he laughed.
In that way he used to laugh.
Oh, the laughter.
Oh, poor little buzzy.
Remember buzzy?
And he was also, you know, I was thinking about the other film that he was.
Here it comes.
Well, I had.
你在生谁的气？是的，我喜欢他在离开后我们变成狂热粉丝的样子。我知道，我知道。好吧，我们之前就这么做了。我们变得害羞。是的。我知道，因为我在想，我在想，《肖申克的救赎》，对吧？
You could always hear a little turn off the highway.
Let's get to the off ramp, Willie.
What's the name of the off ramp today?
It's so sweaty.
What is it?
Yeah, and do you remember that one film?
Yeah.
What's this one called?
你记得吗？我知道。那部电影我看了十万遍。天哪，太棒了。还有《死囚漫步》。这里的导演是谁？顺便说一句，《死囚漫步》。这是他的第二部电影。我想肖恩·潘凭那部电影拿了奥斯卡，
He had a great part of that movie.
My Fidelity.
Oh, God.
That is.
That is terrible.
Bye.
不是吗？我想他拿了。我记得当我家的狗得了癌症，在安乐死之前我带着它进行最后一次散步时，我对它的脸说，我说，这是死狗漫步。感觉太糟糕了。它笑了。它笑了，难道它没笑吗？
哦，它笑了。用它以前那种笑法。哦，那个笑声。哦，可怜的小巴兹。还记得巴兹吗？而且他也是，你知道的，我在想他的另一部电影。它来了。好吧，我……